let's bring in chris bryant should we um
hi chris you saw obviously what happened
last night and we heard from jacob reese
mogu and he needed one vote to win and
he got significantly more than that
well yes but last time when theresa may
um face devoted no confidence uh jacob
rees-mogg said that um
since more backbenchers have voted
against her than for her she had to
resign immediately so jacob rees-mogg is
frankly a terrible hypocrite but
this is one of the problems i think that
the government have got at the moment
which is that um
boris johnson in particular has got at
the moment which is
it's not as if he's got a really
top-class
front bench
i mean it's a pretty
drab
um incompetent tedious cabinet
um and he's not got anybody he's going
to be able to recruit back into it to
make it any better and
do you remember
do you mind if i just do a very brief
bit of greek history or yeah ancient
history and the ba um pyrus was the king
of papyrus
he had what was known as a pyrrhic
victory because he'd won two battles
against the romans in successive years
um but he'd lost so many of his own
troops that he had nobody else to bring
back into the line and for another
battle and that's why we have the
concept of a pyrrhic victory last night
was a pyrrhic victory he won't he's not
got anybody else to um bring into his
government he's he's already made noises
he's offered i don't know how many
people um jobs uh in the hope that um
that would persuade them to vote for him
yesterday and lots of them have
obviously said sorry i'm not interested
i i wouldn't want to serve under you and
i wouldn't be surprised if there'll be a
few ministerial resignations over the
next couple of days because there's a
lot of discontent in the conservative um
government not just the back benches but
um some of the ministers as well so this
can only get worse for the government um
it may take a few months yet
but
he won't last the year
yeah but who okay let me put it this way
who does the labour party
most fear when it comes to those who
might take over from the prime minister
from what you're saying you don't fear
any of them which is a surprise
well i i the weird thing about
you know sometimes i can be very part of
that as you know
um but a lot of the time political life
isn't they partisan you have friends
across the division across the house
and i see lots of people sitting on the
back benches um in the tory party who
are 10 times better than some of the
ministers presently in the government uh
certainly in the cabinet um and
that's going to be the problem if boris
carries on as he seems to intend things
are not going to get better for him who
do i
i mean labor
if i'm just thinking in the interest of
the labor party
last night was brilliant
you have a lame duck
i mean the definition of a lame-up prime
minister um when
he can't even com command um the
confidence of three-fifths of his own
mps he's not going to be able to get you
know significant policies through
parliament and he's going to be
endlessly worrying about um you know
whether there's going to be another vote
of confidence i'm sure the tory party
will change the rules again if they want
to
um and
uh and we've got by-elections coming up
and then of course we've got the
privileges committee so i i just think
uh you know in one sense for the labour
party this is brilliant but it's
terrible for britain
it's really terrible for britain we have
a major international crisis
a food crisis because of what the
russians are doing in ukraine and war on
our state
on our doorstep as it were um or the
doorstep of europe in ukraine
um which may go on for a long time
involving an awful lot of um
death and mutilation and anguish
um and proposing a real challenge
economically for the whole of the rest
of the world and we've got a crisis in
the uk you just mentioned fuel prices i
mean from my constituents in the ronda
that is
that that puts the price of a of filling
your car up dramatically and most people
have to go you know drive to work so um
these problems require a government of
moral authority and
the weirdest thing of all is the tory
party used to be the party of law and
order
how on earth can there be 211 tory mps
who think that law makers can be law
breakers
how did that come to pass
we you know what that's a that's what we
call a rhetorical question in the trade
and we're going to have to leave it
there but thank you very much indeed for
joining us chris bryant thank you